okay hello everyone I am Nicolò and I will talk to
you about records and tuples which is a proposal
for a new JavaScript syntax I'm kind of sorry
it's lunchtime I'm with hangout now and those are
not food however if you stay here with me I have
stickers of the end of fragment tuples so don't
come and ask me I have a lot of them so I worked
on this uh at igalia in partnership with Bloomberg
before seeing what are records and tuples let's
first see what we are trying to solve with this
new JavaScript feature uh so what is our problem
uh one programming there are two main partings
to main way to manage your state your data you can
have multiple objects or immutable State and those
are usually used in object oriented programming
and in functional programming however in many
languages such as JavaScript you can use both
you don't really have to choose you can mix them
and in JavaScript while the mutable part is
really good like we have classes we have a
lot of different things we don't really
have good Primitives for immutable state
there are some very good JavaScript libraries
that gives us this capability they are just not
included in the language itself
for example, the most popular one is immutable.js
how many few have ever used the immutable.js
well quite a bit nice I've I must never use the
immutable.js just like once or two times uh however
uh just for those who don't know what it is it's
a library that provides some structures parallel
to the built-in JavaScript objects but it working
in an immutable way for example we have Maps which
are kind of like objects and you can update those
immutable data structures without modifying the
original one but creating a copy so for example
we can create a new map where "b" is instead of
"2" the original map is not modified and then
immutable.js provides some utilities to compare
to immutable data starters for example we
can check if two maps are equal a according
to immutable.js and it has some utilities
to convert code back to plain JavaScript
another popular library is inner uh email uses
plain JavaScript objects so you don't have to
learn this parallel like immutable data structures
and it provides some utilities to update them
in a way that looks mutable but doesn't really
change the original object so the original object
remain remains unchanged and we get a new object
with updated property and this is again a really
good Library the only problem is that uh well
it has some problems that I'm going to show uh
the main one is that it's a library so you have to
to include in your code and it does not just work
and so as I was saying every library has its own
problems and this is not because of
the library it's because JavaScript
does not give them the tools necessary
to build something that works perfectly
so the one big problems that you have to
learn are completely different things uh
you have to learn like this new equivalent
of objects and arrays you have to learn how
to get properties from them how to update them
and so for example you cannot write code that
bot works that works both with plain JavaScript
objects and with immutable.js you have to choose
and another big problem is that equality is not
agreed upon across everything because JavaScript
has its own definition of equality while for
example limitable.js has its own different
definition of equality so for example if you
create a JavaScript set containing an immutable
list that only contains zero one according to
JavaScript it the set does not contain this other
list which looks the same however according to the
mutable set to the set in the immutable just words
the equality here works and so we like
checking if this list is contained returns true
and this is a problem uh because every Library
used you have to check if it works or not with
the immutable library that you're using uh as
an exam as a practical example assuming that
you have a React component and you are using
immutable.js uh this is a component that at
some point gets rendered in the game and let's
assume that map renderer is a component that
well renders the map the immutable map that we
have and that for some reason this is a very
expensive operation so we want to skip the
rendering the nested component if possible
however and we're always passing the same map or
at least a map with the same contents to these
component So in theory React could skip rendering
it however the map is always the same according
to immutable.js like if we use the equality
function of immutable.js it would have done
true for all those Maps however according
to JavaScript, there are all different Maps
because they're all different objects and so react
re-renders the map renderer component every time
okay so with the records and tuples proposal
we are trying to solve these problems
Records and Tuples are a new type of JavaScript
value they are similar to object and arrays
they're just immutable they even have the same
syntax except that it's prefix within hash
and records and tuples are compared by
their contents rather than by reference
or by pointer which is how objects are
compared like if you have two objects
with the same content they can still
be the same object this is not true
for example tuples two records or tuples
with the same contents are really the same
records and tuples are Primitives so they
have the wrong type of so you can easily check
if something is a record rather than a classic
object and they can only contain other Primitives
why there are Primitives uh because Primitives
are already compared checking their contents for
example two strings are equal if they contain the
same charters even if you didn't create them in
the same place and it's easy to define what deeper
quality means on Primitives because you can just
recursively check their contents for objects
this is more difficult because as we saw for
example with immutable.js there can be different
opinions regarding the quality of objects and also
only using Primitives gives us deep immutability
guarantees so giving us some stronger security
warranties without having to remember for
example to freeze every object every time
and a bit more in detail how are records and
tuples compared well first recursively so uh
two records are equal if every property of the
record is equal and if you find other records
and tuples you check their contents again tuples
are ordered because they're like array So two
tuples are the same not only if they contain the
same values but also if they're the same order
and records are not so uh for records you only
check that for every given property name you
have the same value regardless of the definition
order in records and tuples and NaN values and
are equal and positive negative zero are equal and
this is kind of an edge case but it's something
very important to preserve because it makes it
possible to not worry about 0 and NaN instead
of deep records and double structures and you can
still see if two records of two tuples containing
positive zero negative zero are different using
objectives which is how we already check if you
have a positive or negative zero like outside of
record and tuple and finally since we defined what
it means to be equal for regular Tuple directly in
the language it works everywhere so for example it
works in mapping sets you can have a map where the
key is a tuple or a record so you can have like
a compound key multiple values in the
same key and also like every Library
uh every JavaScript library that exists would
already know how equality for records and doubles
works because it's just the normal JavaScript
quality so if we look again at our React example
but using a record rather than an immutable.js map
this time React does not render the map renderer
component every time because the data is the
same like for real or actually according to React
because it's the same according to JavaScript
and not to some specific library that we chose
okay so records and tuples are immutable
uh but apps are dynamic so we need to like
update our state how do we update records and
doubles we do it in the same way as we update
it's not really update as we create new objects
with different contents without modifying the
original objects so we can just use spread
for example to replace some properties records
and for tuples, we can use all the array methods
that do not mutate the array such as filter
or map or reduce all the methods that return a
new value without modifying the original value
and what about the other array methods so for
example array dot push or array dot shift well for
those it's easy you don't really need those
methods you can just use spread so there are
no alternative for those methods that modified
original right you just create a new Tuple so
spreading the contents of the original one
and adding one element at the end or at the
beginning and the same is for pop or
shift you can you can just use less
then we have a write a field and write a copy
within those methods are really specialized
for mutating stuff and it does not make sense to
have an immutable version of that uh because they
are used for some like performance-critical things
where you need to do as few operations as possible
and this is just not just not possible with tuples
so they're not supported and what about the other
four elements well that are three elements
and then the like setting an array elements like
it makes sense to sort a tuple to get the sorted
version of a tuple the problem is that this sort
array method modifies the original array and so
this doesn't work on immutable things so let's
put aside for a moment to record some tuples
proposal and let's take a quick look at the
change array by copy proposal which is born as a
like child proposal of the records and tuples one
have you ever read them like array.slice().reverse() or array.slice().sort()? I have many times
because many times I want to like reverse an
array without modifying the original version
and having to use two methods is not really
clear like if I'm reading this code why do I
need to first slice it without any arguments to
then reverse it or to then sort it so the change
area by copy proposal introduces alternatives
to these methods that mutate the array when
it's not really necessary for example instead
of array.sort() we now also have array. toSorted()
which returns a new array which is just
well sorted and the same for array.toReverse()
we have to reverse and instead of splice we have
to splice and lastly for setting a specific
element in the array or well for creating a new
array where a specific element has been replaced
we could use two splice interior but let's like
that's probably the most hard to use array methods
so we are also introducing this array.with() that
lets you specify a specific entry of the array
and all these methods have been to the array to
typed array so that they are all consistent
and you can also use them on tuples so that
you can just memorize this shared API that
works across all the array like built-ins and you
don't have to learn different things depending on
whether you want mutable things or immutable
things okay back to records and tuples uh
We've now seen that records and tuples uh like
are compared recursively that their Primitives
contain Primitives we've seen which methods we can
use on them uh there is one more problem there are
Primitives technology content other Primitives
but JavaScript is full of objects like the
DOM is objects every function is an object we have
Maps, Aets, Arrays, Promises almost everything
is an opportunity in JavaScript and we cannot just
say okay you chose to use record and tuples you cannot
use objects anymore that's not realistic so how do
you reference objects inside of records and tuples
well we have explored different alternatives
and none of them was really good preserving this
security and the immutability guarantees
the records and tuples give because
if the goal like referencing multiple objects and
having full immutability are conflicting goals and
there isn't a good way to make them work together
so the solution is records and tuples still cannot
contain objects but you can reference objects
using like Symbol placeholders so you can put
a Symbol in the Record and have a side table
saying okay this Symbol corresponds to this
object and then a side table the other way around
saying this object corresponds to the Symbol so
that you have this one-to-one mapping and you can
translate every object to corresponding primitive
so if I want to get the onclick function for thisRecord
I get this corresponding Symbol and then I
check okay what is the function corresponding to
the Symbol and this might seem really complex but
in practice all that part can be easily abstracted
by library there is no library in npm yet to do so
just because records and tuples only proposal it's
not like implemented yet in most engines but there
is a problem with this approach which is garbage
collection so garbage collection is a mechanism
that the the browser has to avoid using a lot of
memory so if you create many objects as soon as
those objects are not reachable anymore from your
code which means that they're not like stored in a
variable or stored in a property of another object
the JavaScript engine can delete them from
memory those frame some memory the problem with
using Maps is that if you put objects in maps they
cannot be garbage collected anymore because you
could always like as long as you have access to
the map you could like iterate over its elements
and get all its keys so these objects would live
forever and your application would start leaking
a lot of memory and at some point it might crash
and this solution to this is to use weak Maps
rather than Maps the only problem is that weak
Maps cannot contain symbols so a third proposal
which again was born for records and tuples is the
symbols as with WeakMap keys proposal uh so what does
it do well the name might be self-explicative but
uh so we can divide JavaScript values into
categories we have values that can be garbage
collected and values that cannot I'm calling
them forgeable values and I explain why in a
moment so well I'll explain it now let's first
look at the first ball values column first of
all values are values that you can recreate so if
you have a string that contains some contents and
then you later like stop referencing the string
in theory the engine could garbage collect it
but then you can create the same string again
uh like even outside of your program you could
fetch it from a server or like create it from the
number code points so you could create this same
string again and you could observe using Maps or
weakMaps that the original value has been deleted
on the other hand garbage collectible values
are values that you cannot recreate anymore
so if you have an object and you lose access
to this object there is no way you can create
an object which is the same one because for
two object to be the same one it means that
not that they haven't seen contents but that
it was really like created in that single place
and so we have unique symbols that well are unique
by definition so they're also garbage collectible
and we have on the other side registered symbols
which are symbols that are not unique and you can
recreate the same symbol every time by giving
to the Symbol dot function the same description
it's kind of like symbol.iterator or symbol dot uh
symbol of iterator that you can reuse many times
and lastly with this proposal we will also
have records and tuples which are kind of
both sides and this is kind of strange
but if you think about it a record that
contains a symbol that you cannot recreate
uh can be garbage collected because if you
do not have the symbol anymore you cannot
recreate the same record anymore well a
record that contains for example only strings
is forgeable because you can just take the same
string like recreate the same strings
put them together to create the record
at the moment only objects are allowed as weakMap's keys
um as you might imagine this proposal extends the
valid with my keys to also unique Symbols so
that uh we can now use weakMap'a keys to have
weakMaps to actually have this symbol to object
mapping to put things in records and tuples
so this was a very lightweight
overview I did um about
there is one big question like I've shown
you like records and tuples change
methods symbols with Map keys but is this
something that you can actually use like
can you go home and start using them tomorrow
or on Monday tomorrow and Sunday don't use them
well yes and no so those are only proposals
they will hopefully be added to a JavaScript
version in the future uh there are at a good
stage in the standardization process so they
it's at this point certain that it will be added
it will take time however you can start using
some of them for the change drive by copy
there are already many Polyfill such as
es-shims and core-js yes core-js is quite popular
maybe some of you already use that and also it
has been released in Safari 16 last week so
I just updated these slides yesterday night
because I saw a tweet about this Safari release
notes and Change Array by Copy was there so you can
already start using this proposal in a browserright now
Symbols as WeakMap key is unfortunately
not polyfillable because it's adding a real new
capability to the language like something that
cannot be done in any other way and it has
not been released yet in any browser so
we can only leak memory for now when they uh
hopefully next year uh browsers we're still
implementing Symbols as WeakMap key and we can
actually have these mappings in a memory safe way
and finally records and tuples well records
and tuples is new syntax so you cannot really
just polyfill that however there is a Babel
plugin uh does any one of you use the Babel
nice okay there is a Babel plugin uh for
those who know Babel I'll let you compile
modern JavaScript syntax or proposals to older
syntax so that you can use them even in other
browsers or in browsers that do not support the
syntax that you want to use uh there is a Babel
plugin that allows you to compile a record and tuples
so that it works in every browser uh
and I don't suggest using that in production
because proposals can change there are a lot of
very cool JavaScript proposals uh and it's very
important that people test them so that we see
if they work or not like if it's a good idea or
not but please never use those in production yet
and also we have an online playground so uh there
is some like well an online playground where you
can actually type your records and tuples code
and see how it works see how the quality works
uh test I think it also supports the Change
Array by Copy methods so you can it's kind
of like a browser console except that it supports
records and tuples uh you probably don't need to
copy the link like if you Google for record and tuples
playground it will be one of the first few results
and that's all uh if you have any questions I'm
happy to answer them like just look for me around
uh I'm the one with the pink hoodie uh you can
also contact me on Twitter for any question
related uh like either to this proposals I'm
working on or to other JavaScript proposals uh
or I'm into anything that I do that you might want
to not want about or you can contact me on Matrix
which no one knows but no one uses it but in my
opinion is the best chat protocol that exists
and that's all thanks and let's all have lunch now